there's been this trend that we've seen
globalization as a universal positive
you know it's it's a great thing we're
more interconnected than ever with this
virus is pandemic that has swept the
globe aided and abetted by you know the
fact that we travel everywhere are we
now going to look at globalization as
being something that we embrace without
considering many of the disadvantages
and flaws behind it globalization is
dead I mean it should have died a long
time ago but it you know it's kind of
struggle on but we will you know that
this period of globalization we lived
through between nineteen I would make it
1989 to 2010 or thereabouts it was the
second age of globalization the first
age of globalization was 1870s in 1914
and yeah there was free trade and
bankers in London were selling bonds to
investors in New York one on Argentine
credit and you know letters of credit
we're moving there's trade moving all
over the world and you know that it kind
of resembled the late 20th century and
then it hit a brick wall at seventy
miles an hour called World War one and
the New York Stock Exchange was closed
for five months between August and
December 1914 and as we're most major
stock exchanges around the world and the
gold standard ended immediately people
went through the pretense of having gold
what they did is they hoarded the
physical gold and just printed money so
said that ended and then you know you
know the rest hyperinflation in the
early twenties Depression 1930s World
War two Cold War you know and it was
until the fall of communism and in
stages between 1989 and 1991 that we got
back to globalization but it was it the
second time the first time was real the
second time was a fraud you had people
like you know Jeffrey Sachs at Columbia
and Richard Haass or the Council on
Foreign Relations and a lot of others
promoting this but what it really was
was was an enormous theft from the
United States of financial capital
intellectual capital intellectual
property etc for the benefit
of China and I'd like to say that you
know the authenware sent a poor
communist is a rich communist so what we
did is we created a lot of rich
communists and here we are but now the
globalization is dead it's been
completely discredited Tom Friedman and
Richard on their end Sachs and the rest
can go off and write their papers but
the real world has has moved on
[Music]